why didn't you let her go why couldn't
he let her go there was no reason to
keep her he had the car he had her money
he had everything Marilyn Marquez had a
simple question for the man now
convicted of killing her mother can't he
tell me why he killed my mother why it's
all I want to know why
why and were you mean to her Christopher
Mack taking a plea deal in the August
1994 murder of 81 year old Ada priolo
the grandmother abducted and stuffed
inside the trunk of her car my mother
most wanted more than that it's a cold
case eight news now investigator George
Knapp covered for years in 2019 new DNA
evidence LED detectives to Mac he was
already in prison on other charges
police say Max fingerprints were found
in five spots on priolo's car but
because of his age at the time his
prints weren't in the system grandma
said he needed to answer for it Mack
taking an Alfred plea meaning he
believes the evidence against him should
the case go to trial would lead to a
conviction briolo's granddaughter
fighting for this day for years I don't
think we'll ever know why but for now I
have to find closure knowing I did all I
could and pushed off and pushed off and
pushed off you know make every time it
got pushed off it was another sentence
for us for the family for my mom you
know we didn't deserve that so the the
fact that the system did something is is
amazing but this system is just still
100 completely broken the judge asking
Mack if he wanted to speak before she
sentenced him
Max attorney had previously argued that
his client had already served enough
time in prison for other crimes and
should be released in the next year when
he could be released we don't know I'm
David charns 8 News Now
Mack was 17 at the time of the murder
his fingerprints were added into this
system after he committed other crimes
those crimes he's already serving time
for in prison if you want to see more